these long queues outside kabul's
passport office
tell a story of a nation on the edge
as u.s and nato soldiers return home
hundreds of afghans
are trying to escape theirs
i think that our country is at the verge
of collapse and the security situation
is very bad
there are no jobs i'm a student and i'm
not able to continue my studies
therefore i'm here to get a passport
since may
the taliban's advance has been fast and
strategic
its fighters are surrounding cities and
towns
and they are now battling for control of
the southeastern city of ghazni
just hours away from kabul
afghan forces are fighting back but this
time
without foreign troops on their side
the afghan government has decided to
retake the cities districts and villages
that the enemy has taken with cowardice
or propaganda
and we are clearing these areas the
afghan special forces have advanced
weapons
and we assure our people that there is
no problem
but for afghans in the north in kunduz
sheltering in tents made of rags and
stones
the daily struggle is against hunger in
three months of fighting
many have lost everything
here we have no help and we sleep with
empty stomachs under the sun
we have been here for a month or 20 days
and no one has come to ask about our
situation
back in kabul for these families a
passport means a chance of a future
for a generation of afghans who've only
known war
priyanka gupta al jazeera